Wonder comes to us from the director of
the perks of being a wallflower and
stars Julia Roberts Owen Wilson and
young Jacob Tremblay as Augie a young
boy who was born with many health
threatening facial deformities who has
had to go through many surgeries to make
sure that he could live and eventually
he has to go to school and as I'm sure a
lot of you know for someone in his
position that's going to be very
difficult and this film explores that
not just through the eyes of Augie
himself but his family members and his
close friends which is one of the
reasons why wonder stands out amongst
other films that have a similar story
this shows how it affects not just young
Augie but everyone around him and in so
doing you get a really well-rounded
viewpoints of how people react to things
and the way things can affect everyone
not just one person commonly in films
like this you focus on the character
who's dealing with whatever affliction
he or she has and maybe one close friend
or family member but in this case we see
how it affects his sister his parents a
kid at school his sister's friend and we
understand how the way people react to
young Augie
can have implications on not just Augie
himself but everyone around him and so
it's all the more encouraging to young
kids to treat people with respect no
matter what their situation in life is
which is why this film has such a
beautiful message it's not just about
treating Augie with the respect he
deserves as a human being but it's
message reveals that a small comment or
a little joke
or something could have a domino effect
and it encourages people and hopefully
kids who see this film because it is
family-friendly it's read PG to treat
people the way they want to be treated I
thought this film was really special
Owen Wilson is really good in this film
he gives one of his best performances
I've seen in a long time I really
related to him he has a lot of sequences
where he sits down and talks with Augie
kind of man-to-man you know and he's
like look this is what the world is like
and you kind of have to deal with it
Julia Roberts is also really good here
she doesn't try to steal the show either
she knows this is about Jacob Tremblay
his performance and this is definitely a
showcase for him and some oscar-worthy
makeup
young Tremblay is proving once again to
be one of the best young actors of his
generation he tugged on my heartstrings
quite a bit and that's something I want
to talk about whenever a film is about a
character dealing with some sort of
mental deficiency or physical deficiency
critics who don't like it often target
the same reasons they say it's too
sentimental it's too melodramatic or
perhaps it's manipulative emotionally
and that can certainly be said of
certain films in the past and I wouldn't
disagree if they were to say that about
films of this nature that I have seen
before but I just think it's a really
easy criticism films that are about
something that instantly makes you feel
sad you can look at and say well that's
kind of manipulative emotionally and
it's just an easy target for my emotions
and I can say that the film portrays it
in a very accurate way and I know this
from experience some of you may know
before I decided to pursue a career in
film I've worked for a school board I
was an aide for children who had
physical deficiencies or mental
deficiencies some kids didn't have fully
developed legs some children were barely
there at all mentally and they went to
school as a way to hopefully connect
with other people and I saw on a daily
basis almost the way certain kids
treated those children like Outsiders
they would stare they would joke with
their friends and it was incredibly sad
for me to watch and other kids a very
select few were supportive there were
specific kids who would volunteer to aid
a child in a wheelchair and wheel him or
her out to the bus and no one was
telling him to do that so this film kind
of struck a chord with me because I saw
a lot of kids deal with this very thing
in school and I saw a lot of kids who
were supportive they're always gonna be
bullies but the film is accurate and
showing that there are always a few kids
with good head on their shoulders who
are trying to do something right
this film is extremely emotionally
satisfying Auggie is a very likable
character his sister in the film is also
really great and she has
a storyline that I thought was even more
powerful in a way as I said it explores
the way people treat one person and the
implications it gives to someone else
and his sister has a very powerful
storyline but it's also one of the
weaker elements of the film she has a
friend in the movie that she has become
distant with and the way that wrapped up
just felt very rushed in regards to
flaws since I'm on that subject that's
probably the only real thing I can
pinpoint in the movie as something that
I went ah that's that could have been
better
certain things are rushed because they
are trying to wrap up a lot of different
storylines for this film to work and for
it to feel like it's whole and some
storylines just kind of wrap up really
quick in one scene Mandy Patinkin shows
up as a principal in the school and I
had no idea he was in this movie and he
was terrific everyone's really great
this is a film that I think kids can
really benefit from seeing a film that
could perhaps encourage children and
maybe even adults to treat people better
which I mean what's wrong with that I'm
gonna give Wonder and a - I would
definitely recommend seeing this film
guys it took me a few weeks to see it
but I'm glad that I finally did thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]